[Music]
which actor who passed away in 2021 was
a key player on peewee's playhouse and
who inspired a whole new generation of
actors keep watching for those and more
acting greats we lost in 2021.
actor john paragon died in april 2021 at
66. he was best known for playing zombie
the genie on peewee's playhouse paragon
met series star paul rubins through the
groundlings the renowned improv troupe
that launched will ferrell kristen wiig
and melissa mccarthy on the path to
hollywood stardom rubens recalled on
instagram
john was sly and wickedly funny he
became best friends instantly in a group
of exceptionally talented and funny
people he stuck out on top of playing
the disembodied genie paragon also
provided the voice of terry the
pterodactyl and was also a writer and
director on several playhouse episodes
he appeared in a number of other hit tv
shows over the years most notably
seinfeld his character cedric was a
thorn in the side of kramer in three
memorable episodes including the super
nazi
actor frank bonner best known for
playing the spectacularly dressed herb
tarlek on the classic sitcom wkrp in
cincinnati died in june 2021 according
to tmz he was 79. his daughter broke the
news posting on the official wkrp
facebook page he loved his fans and was
still signing autograph requests up
until the last few weeks of his illness
thank you to all who followed his career
he will be forever missed i love you
i really do
bonner made his first on-screen
appearance in the 1967 horror film the
equinox a journey into the supernatural
but he was best known for his tv work
after early appearances in shows like
manix and the fbi bonner landed the
career defining role of herb tarlek he
portrayed the character in all but two
episodes of the series his co-star lani
anderson told the associated press he
was one of the funniest men i had the
pleasure of working with and he was the
nicest man i have ever known
actor joanne linville played a romulan
commander in star trek the original
series and went on to appear in the
likes of gunsmoke barnaby jones and
hawaii 5-0 she died in june 2021 at 93.
her family shared in a statement she
lived a full life she was one whose
spirit passion for art and life was an
inspiration to all who had the pleasure
of knowing her
linville made her debut in the 50s with
movies like the goddess and copper
canyon but she was perhaps best known
for her memorable guest role in the
enterprise incident in which her romulan
commander captures captain kirk and mr
spark falling in love with the latter
it will be our secret
british actor jackie lane best known for
playing the doctor's companion dodo
chaplet in the long-running sci-fi
series doctor who died in june 2021 she
was 79. after getting her start in local
theater as a teenager by the 1960s lane
had secured regular theater work she
moved to london to pursue a tv career
and landed a role on the bbc's
short-lived soap opera compact having
appeared in 19 episodes of doctor who
she was then let go from the series
disheartened lane left the industry for
years but kept taria to the ground as an
agent for voice actors
actor and renowned drama coach andre
trey died in june 2021 at 81. her son
home alone star devin retreat confirmed
the news on instagram writing she was in
her bed surrounded by her family
the family requests privacy and
appreciates your sentiments starting out
in the industry as a miss america
contestant in 1958 she starred on
broadway and landed a few small tv and
movie roles in the 70s but retreat would
become best known for her mentoring in
later years
she prepared her son for his turn as
buzz mcallister and home alone and was
influential in the career of catch-22
star graham patrick martin who tweeted
andre retrey is the reason i am an actor
forever grateful
bulgarian singer and actor lorena
kambarova who featured in a number of
horror movies died of pneumonia in may
2021. the condition was caused by
covid19 according to the russian outlet
gazita she was just 30 years old her
career began in her native country with
the series liaisons in 2015. two years
later she appeared in three horror films
including a prequel to toby hooper's the
texas chainsaw massacre 2017's
leatherface the final product didn't
fare all that well with critics but the
los angeles times noted it's the best
chainsaw movie that doesn't have
directed by toby hooper in the credits
the arena landed a spot in 2017's night
world and then day of the dead bloodline
in what would become one of her final
roles the actor played dr sandy peterson
in doom annihilation
soap star stuart damon who played dr
alan quartermaine in over 300 episodes
of general hospital died in june 2021.
he was 84 years old his son recalled to
kabc general hospital was his favorite
place to be he loved playing allen and
was always so appreciative of that role
and that job it was his passion having
gotten his start in theater damon
launched his tv career in the uk on
shows like the saint the new avengers
and the champions he worked out of
london for over a decade but trekked
back to the states for the iconic soap
he said in a 2010 interview i was
thinking general hospital might be a
13-week gig and 31 years later i was
still there his character was killed off
in 2007 but he continued to return in
flashbacks a soap veteran went on to
appear in as the world turns and days of
our lives
model and actor daniel mickelson died at
just 23 years old on july 4th 2021. he
was best known for his role on brett
tv's money there's no time like the
present his sister model meredith
mickelson revealed the news on instagram
writing my heart is shattered and to
write this feels so wrong yesterday i
lost my brother best friend and the
other half of my heart there wasn't a
person i loved more on this earth
mickelson made his acting debut in 2019
playing con man billy on the manny web
series the atlanta born up and comer
landed his first film role soon after
appearing in the indie horror the killer
clown meets the candyman he also
reportedly was just beginning his
modelling career meredith's tribute post
was quickly flooded with heartfelt
messages from other famous faces jordan
woods sent her prayers while paris
hilton wrote of her sadness about the
news among the most heartbreaking
tributes was the one made by daniel's
girlfriend maddie haley she wrote i wish
my plans to spend the rest of my life
with you weren't stripped away from me
like this
filmmaker director and actor robert
downey senior father of robert downey jr
died of parkinson's in july 2021. he was
85 the new york native enlisted in the
army when he was still in his teens and
would land in minor league baseball
before writing his first play after
cutting his teeth with off off-broadway
productions he made the low budget
feature babo73 while his films were
never box office draws the critically
acclaimed works would inspire a
generation of filmmakers one was paul
thomas anderson who went on to cast
downey senior in 1997's boogie nights
his best known film as a director was
1969's putney swope it was added to the
u.s national film registry in 2016.
veteran actor suzanne douglas died of
cancer in july 2021 at 64. she starred
in the 90s sitcom the parenthood and
later appeared in ava duvernay's
critically acclaimed drama when they see
us duvernay described her in a tweet
writing suzanne was a quiet elegant
force a gentle woman a gem of a lady a
confident caring actor who breathed life
into the words and made them shimmer i'm
grateful that our paths in this life
crossed douglas grew up in a rough part
of chicago and went on to study theater
at illinois state university alongside
the likes of john malkovich and gary
sinise douglas made her on-screen debut
in 1981 and would become a sitcom
mainstay the following decade in what
was her best known role douglas played
matriarch jerry peterson on the
parenthood from 1995 to 1999.
texas native charles robinson best known
for playing court clerk mack on the
sitcom night court died in july 2021. he
was 75. robinson made his big screen
debut in jack nicholson's 1971
directorial debut drive he said and by
the early 80s he was landing recurring
tv roles in shows like buffalo bill but
in 1984 he took his career defining turn
as mack the popular clerk on night court
he once said in an interview most people
really liked the mag because mack kind
of kept the lid over the pot i will live
with night cord for the rest of my life
i could do films theater television
forever and it's always a night court
one of his final projects was freeform's
love in the time of corona in which his
wife co-starred us as nurse cheers to
you my dear
[Music]
according to the hollywood reporter
actor robert sarkee died in june 2021.
he was 89. sarki looked so much like
humphrey bogart that he once starred in
a film called the man with bogart's face
did i see you sometime on television in
old movies that's somebody else he sure
look like you now i look like him
while sarki made an appearance in a
music video for phil collins song i wish
it would rain down he was primarily
known for comedy the 1999 rom-com blast
from the past became his final role but
fans of action flakes were no doubt
recognized sarki as a control tower
engineer in die hard 2.
martial arts movie icon sunny chiba died
in august 2021 of complications from
covid he was 82. he made his
international debut in the 1970s with
the street fighter and later appeared in
kill bill and the fast and the furious
tokyo drift a black belt in numerous
disciplines chiba was the real deal when
it came to martial arts his first
crossover success was 1974's the street
fighter the dub of which became a cult
favourite in the us the film would
inspire quentin tarantino who referenced
it in his script for 1993's true romance
chiba passed away before his final
feature film the gangster movie bond of
justice kizuna was released tv legend ed
asner best known for playing news
producer lou grant on both the mary
tyler moore show and the series lou
grant died in august 2021 at 91. his
family shared in a tweet we are sorry to
say that our beloved patriarch passed
away this morning peacefully words
cannot express the sadness we feel with
a kiss on your head good night dad we
love you you got spunk
well yes i hate
after starring on broadway and in film
and tv asner hit the big time when he
was cast as cranky lou grant on the mary
tyler moore show a role that would
provide him the chance to flex his
dramatic muscles and the spin-off lou
grant across both shows the role with
net asner five of his seven emmys of
course younger audiences probably know
asner best as santa claus from elf and
as the voice of carl frederickson in up
asner was inducted into the academy of
television arts and sciences hall of
fame in 1996.
emmy nominated actor michael k williams
was found dead in his new york apartment
on september 6 2021. he was 54. best
known for his spellbinding turns on
numerous hbo shows and movies a rep for
the network said in a statement he was a
member of the hbo family for more than
20 years while the world is aware of his
immense talents as an artist we knew
michael as a dear friend who was beloved
by all who had the privilege to work
with him
on a personal level i truly believe that
all my characters they choose me
williams worked as a background dancer
for madonna crystal waters and george
michael before switching his focus to
acting he was soon spotted by none other
than tupac shakua who pushed for him to
be cast in the 1996 film bullet williams
would go on to play a number of gangster
roles in the years that followed but his
portrayal of openly gay stick-up man
omar little in the wire garnered
widespread praise the actor told the new
york times omar definitely helped soften
the blow of homophobia in my community
and it opened up a dialogue his most
recent work was as montrose freeman in
lovecraft country which earns the
versatile star his fifth and ultimately
final emmy nod comedian and actor norm
mcdonald died of cancer in september
2021. he was 61. the tv icon starred in
films including dirty work and screwed
but was best known for his time on
saturday night live macdonald kept his
diagnosis secret for nine years as a
friend of his told deadline he didn't
want it to affect the way the audience
or any of his loved ones saw him norm
was a pure comic he once wrote that a
joke should catch someone by surprise
and should never pander he certainly
never pandered a 1990 appearance on star
search led to tv writing gigs and
macdonald soon found himself penning
gags for roseanne but in 1993 nbc came
calling and macdonald began a five-year
stint on snl that's remembered chiefly
for his time fronting weekend update his
turn as anchor was defined by his
relentless criticism of o.j simpson and
his murder trial which some say
contributed to his axing from the show
apparently mcdonald himself believed
that his humor was just too out there as
he once told the new york times we were
doing experimental stuff mcdonald went
on to star on the norm show and worked
on several movies with former snl cast
members most notably adam sandler's
billy madison eddie murphy's dr
doolittle as lucky the dog and rob
schneider's the animal
actor james michael tyler was known all
around the world for his portrayal of
gunther the eccentric and shy manager of
central perk on friends he died of
prostate cancer in october 2021 at 59
his rep shared in a statement the world
knew him as gunther the seventh friend
but michael's loved ones knew him as an
actor musician cancer awareness advocate
and loving husband if you met him once
he made a friend for life his characters
crush on jennifer aniston's rachel
greene became a running gag over the
course of 10 seasons and it was a
remarkable storyline when he considered
that gunther wasn't even supposed to be
a fully realised character tyler was
originally cast as a background actor
but friends co-creators marta kaufman
and david crane saw something more they
said in a statement his unique spirit
caught her eye and we knew he had to
make him a character he made gunther's
unrequited love incredibly relatable he
went on to appear in several other hit
series but he'll always be remembered as
part of the friend's family jennifer
aniston took to instagram to write in
tyler's memory friends would not have
been the same without you thank you for
the laughter you brought to the show and
all of our lives you will be so missed
comedian and actor anthony aj johnson
died in september 2021 and 55. he was
best known for his standout turn as
iselle in the classic comedy friday
that's his rep told the hollywood
reporter we lost an icon he has left
with us amazing memories of his laughter
dynamic acting skills but most of all
his enormous personality and heart of
gold co-writer and co-star of the stoner
comedy ice cube tweeted he was a
naturally funny dude who was straight
out of compton at the same time sorry i
couldn't bring your character ezell back
to the big screen in last friday
according to johnson he was supposed to
reprise his role in 2000s next friday
but cube cut him out from the movie to
save money he told flag tv that he and
cube shook hands on a figure only for
cube to hire someone else and begin
shooting early without telling johnson
have you made it out of compton you can
make it anywhere
character actor dean stockwell died in
november 2021 he was 85. stockwell
appeared alongside the likes of errol
flynn frank sinatra and gene kelly as a
child and after falling out of love with
acting he experienced a career revival
in the 80s appearing in paris texas as
well as the david lynch films june and
blue velvet he also played a crime boss
in jonathan demi's married to the mob
which led to an oscar nom for best
supporting actor he became beloved by
sci-fi fans for his turn as cigar
munching ladies man al calavichi on
quantum leap from 1989 to 1993. scott
bakula who starred on the show paid
tribute to stockwell in a statement
recalling having been a famous child
actor he had a soft spot for every young
actor who came on our set i loved him
dearly and was honored to know him he
made me a better human being
stockwell went on to land roles on
stargate sg1 star trek enterprise and
battle star galactica
character actor art lefleur was best
known for his turn as baseball legend
babe ruth in the 1993 film the sandlot
he died in november 2021 at age 78 of
parkinson's his wife shelley confirmed
on facebook he was a generous and
selfless man which carried over to his
acting but more importantly it was who
he was for his family and friends the
fleur originally moved to california in
1975 to become a screenwriter he went on
to land roles in 1989's field of dreams
and 1992's mr baseball but fans never
forgot the sandlot the floor once told
media mike's when i went into the
audition i went in as babe i went in
with a cigar the babe always had a cigar
actor jerry morgan died in november 2021
he was just 28 best known for his turn
as aagi foster in the zombie comedy
scout's guide to the zombie apocalypse
his rep confirmed to the hollywood
reporter it was a shock and devastated
all of us who loved him he will be
dearly missed scout's guide to the
zombie apocalypse was morgan's acting
debut he went on to feature in a number
of other teen comedies playing a hacker
in compadres and later appearing in
sierra burgess as a loser and camp manor
he returned to the big screen in 2020
co-starring in the critically acclaimed
sci-fi adventure film max reload and the
nether blasters actor heath freeman was
best known for playing serial killer
howard epps on bones as well as turns on
ncis and raising the bar he died in 2021
at the age of 41. his rep said in a
statement we are truly devastated at the
loss he was a brilliant human being with
an intense and soulful spirit freeman
made his small screen debut in a 2001
episode of er and in 2003 he landed on
ncis but by 2005 he made his first
appearance as howard epps on season 1 of
bones freeman appeared in three features
in 2021 including the luke wilson lead
football flick 12 mighty orphans
new york-born actor yafet koto who
appeared opposite roger moore as a
corrupt caribbean politician in the
james bond film live and let die and
later played engineer dennis parker in
ridley scott's 1979 sci-fi flick alien
died in the philippines in march
his wife confirmed the news in a
facebook post writing you played a
villain on some of your movies but for
me you're a real hero a good man a good
father a good husband and a decent human
being he was 81. koto made his movie
debut aged 23 in nothing but a man a
film about a black couple dealing with
racial discrimination in 1960s alabama
his sheer size led to him being cast in
a variety of hard man roles in the years
that followed something that always
bothered him he once told the baltimore
sun i want to try to play a much more
sensitive man there is an aspect of
black people's lives that is not running
or jumping other notable credits include
the stephen king adaptation the running
man in which koto fought for his freedom
alongside arnold schwarzenegger and the
90s police procedural series homicide
life on the street
award-winning actress jessica walter who
won an emmy for her turn as a san
francisco cop in ironside spin-off amy
prentice and became known to later
generations for playing lucille bluth in
arrested development and voicing mallory
archer in archer died in her sleep in
march 2021. daughter brook bowman said
in a statement a working actor for over
six decades her greatest pleasure was
bringing joy to others through her
storytelling both on screen and off
while her legacy will live on through
her body of work she will also be
remembered by many for her wit class and
overall joy the verve she was 80 years
old the new york-born walter began her
career on broadway and quickly started
turning heads picking up the clarence
derwent award for most promising
newcomer for her work in the show photo
finish she continued to impress after
making the move to the big screen where
walter played clint eastwood's
knife-wielding ex-girlfriend in the
actor's directorial debut
1971's play misty for me earning a
golden globe nomination in the process
she was up for multiple emmys over the
course of her career including for
arrested development i don't have the
milk of mother's kindness in me anymore
yeah that otter's been dry for a while
though has it
i know
[Music]
british character actor paul ritter who
went praise for his powerful performance
in hbo's golden globe winning
mini-series chernobyl died of a brain
tumor in april 2021 at the age of 54.
rita was well known in theater
communities on both sides of the
atlantic having been nominated for both
an olivier award and a tony award in his
time he made his on-screen bow in 1992
with an appearance in a long-running
police procedural the bill he went on to
carve out a career as a prolific tv
actor alongside his appearance in
chernobyl his best known performance
came in the british sitcom friday night
dinner where he played oddball dad
martin goodman robert popper creator of
friday night dinner said that he was
devastated at this terribly sad news in
a tribute tweet paul was a lovely
wonderful human being kind funny super
caring and the greatest actor i ever
worked with
grammy nominated rapper and actor dmx
whose songs regularly broke the
billboard hot 100 in the late 90s and
early north died after being
hospitalized in april 2021. he was
rushed to a critical care unit following
a drug overdose but ultimately passed
away at the age of 50. born earl simmons
in mount vernon new york dmx spent much
of his childhood in the care system
after being removed from his physically
abusive mother he began developing his
gritty stage persona darkman x during
his time and he remained true to his
name as his peers started to gravitate
towards designer labels and smoother
beats songs like what's my name and
party up up in here had made him a star
come the turn of the millennium and
hollywood soon came calling dmx appeared
in a string of action movies around this
time for example there was 2000's romeo
must die a martial arts heavy
shakespeare transplant starring jet li
and aaliyah and then dmx headlined in
2001's exit wounds and 2003's cradle to
the grave alongside steven seagal and
jet li respectively he never walked away
from acting and he was still active in
the industry at the time of his death
british actress helen mccrory best known
for her terms as narcissa malfoy in the
harry potter movies and aunt polly in
all five series of peaky blinders died
in april 2021 she was 52. mccrory was
born in london but moved to cameroon and
then tanzania with her diplomat dad when
she was just a toddler she returned to
the uk for her studies and after a year
in italy she enrolled at drama center
london she made her tv debut in 1993 and
appeared in her first movie the kate
beckinsale led thriller uncovered the
following year she went on to appear in
films like the count of monte cristo
helen mirren's the queen and the james
bond instalment skyfall but she never
lost touch with her theatre roots
olympia dukakis the star of the stage
and screen who won an oscar for her turn
as cher's meddling mother in 80s rom-com
moonstruck died in may 2021. her brother
confirmed in a facebook post she was 89
a daughter of greek immigrants dukakis
was born in massachusetts and attended
boston university where she mastered in
performing arts she met actor producer
louis zorich after moving to new york
and they would tie the knot in 1962 the
year she made her debut by the mid-1960s
she had two obie awards to her name and
was well on her way to becoming a
respected broadway star though she'll
likely be remembered by most for her
work on the screen dukakis was named
best supporting actress at both the
academy awards and the golden globes for
her performance as rose castorini in
moonstruck sally field who worked with
dukakis on steel magnolias called her
quote unique and talented and
one-of-a-kind in her own tribute
beloved hollywood veteran norman lloyd
who was one of the oldest living actors
in the business died in may 2021 at the
age of 106. the new jersey born brooklyn
reyes lloyd got his first break in 1932
when he was a student at new york
university he would eventually end up
working with orson welles playing cena
the poet in wells famous adaptation of
julius caesar his first film alfred
hitchcock's saboteur soon followed the
hit spy thriller was the beginning of a
long-lasting professional relationship
between hitchcock and lloyd he went on
to produce and or direct over 250
episodes of alfred hitchcock presents
and the alfred hitchcock in the 50s and
60s lloyd was nominated for a prime time
emmy for his work on the tv movie steam
bath in the 70s and in the following
decade he became known for nbc medical
drama saint elsewhere appearing as
daniel auslander between 1982 and 1988.
other notable roles include peter weir's
dead poet society martin scorsese the
age of innocence and charlie chaplin's
limelight
comedian and actor paul mooney who
regularly collaborated with richard
pryor in the 1970s and 80s and later
became known for his work on in living
color and chappelle show died of a heart
attack in may 2021 he was 79. mooney met
pryor at a party in the late 1960s and
the pair quickly hit it off they ended
up pending an episode of samford and sun
together and would collaborate many more
times in the years that followed
including on the variety series the
richard pryor show the stand-up film
richard pryor live on the sunset strip
and on prior's biographical vehicle jojo
dancer your life is calling mooney
brought his patented style of comedy to
kenyan ivory wayans in living color in
the 90s and in the following decade he
became a writer on another hit sketch
show chappelle's show mooney also
appeared on screen in chappelle's show
playing characters such as a very
opinionated movie critic and a
nostradamus parody notable big screen
credits include the buddy holly story in
which he played seminal singer sam cook
spike leaves bamboozled and the mike
epps led comedy meet the blacks mooney's
final film
former child actor kevin clark who
played percussionist turned drummer
freddie jones in the jack black film
school of rock died after being hit by a
motorist in may 2021 clark was riding
his bicycle in his home city of chicago
when he was struck by a car he was
pronounced dead at illinois masonic
medical center around 45 minutes later
he was 32. clark landed his part in
richard linklater's school of rock his
one and only acting credit after he
tugged along with a friend to the
auditions his mother alison clark told
the chicago sometimes he just kind of
shined he took it on right away but he
never really acted afterward he did
however keep the music up clark went on
to play in a number of bands in the
chicago area and even taught some
classes robbie goldberg who played with
clark in the band robbie gold said he
was motivated and loved to write songs
his hollywood career was short but clark
was a standout performer in school of
rock a cult favorite that spawned a
broadway show and a tv adaptation he was
photographed alongside co-star jack
black as recently as 2018 and black said
in an instagram tribute kevin is gone
way too soon beautiful soul so many
great memories heartbroken
two-time tony award nominee samuel e
wright most famous for his iconic
portrayal of sebastian the crab in
disney's a little mermaid died of
prostate cancer in may 2021 deadline
confirmed he was 74. a south carolina
native began his career on broadway
appearing in the original production of
jesus christ superstar in 1971. he made
his tv debut in 1976 and went on to land
apart in 1988's bird the forest whitaker
led biopic about jazz musician charlie
parker he voiced king triton's 4th right
advisor sebastian in disney's animated
classic the little mermaid the following
year a role he would reprise many times
in tv spin-offs and related disney media
he once told entertainment weekly
sebastian has given me what i've always
wanted as an actor and that's
immortality as far as i'm concerned
that's why i'm in the business i want
the whole world to love me remember me
forever wright got the chance to portray
another iconic disney character when the
lion king came to broadway in 1997
playing the role of simba's father
mufasa
veteran tv actor robert hogan died of
complications from pneumonia in may 2021
he was 87. the new york-born actor
served with the us army in korea and
briefly trained as an engineer upon
returning but an aptitude test told him
that he was in the wrong field hogan
secured a place at the american academy
of dramatic arts and went on to become a
stalwart on the small screen for many
hogan was best known for his recurring
roles on classic abc shows the young
marrieds peyton's place and petticoat
affair though younger viewers will no
doubt remember him from his turn in
hbo's the wire hogan portrayed louis
sodbarka father and moral compass to
pablo scribers nick zabotka in four 2002
episodes of the hit show
renowned character actor ned beatty who
played ill-fated city boy bobby tripp in
john borman's 1972 classic deliverance
died of natural causes in june 2021. he
was 83. a native of kentucky beatty made
his acting debut in his late teens
scoring a singing part in a local stage
production he went on to feature in the
original production of the great white
hope which moved to broadway and ran
until 1970. two years later beatty made
his memorable and haunting movie debut
and deliverance he would remain best
known for borman's film but beti's most
celebrated performance actually came a
few years after it he was nominated for
best supporting actor for his work and
network you have meddled with the primal
forces of nature mr bill and i won't
have it eighty would go on to work with
many more of hollywood's biggest
directors including richard donner
steven spielberg john cassavetes and
robert altman
ohio native lisa baines who was in 80s
films cocktail and young girls and later
appeared in gun girl and a cure for
wellness died after a hit and run in
june 2021. baines was taken to mount
sinai morningside hospital but she died
10 days later she was 65. bane's career
in acting began in the city where her
life was tragically taken she studied at
new york's juilliard school and appeared
in numerous broadway shows she made her
movie debut in tony richardson's the
hotel new hampshire in 1984 and by the
end of the decade she was sharing the
screen with tom cruise playing wealthy
bar fly bonnie in cocktail she worked
largely in tv during the 1990s
co-starring in the emmy nominated drama
series the trials of rosie o'neil before
a string of guest roles in the likes of
l.a law star trek deep space nine and
frasier baines would continue to appear
regularly on american tv screens with
casting directors often keen to take
advantage of her age-defying looks
philadelphia-born actress marion ramsey
best known for playing soft-spoken
officer laverne hooks in the police
academy movies died in january 2021. her
agency told the hollywood reporter the
statement read marion carried with her a
kindness and permeating light that
instantly filled a room upon her arrival
the dimming of her light is already felt
by those who knew her well we will miss
her and always love her no cause of
death was released she was 73. ramsay
made her first appearance as officer
hooks in 1984's police academy after
spending more than a decade in the
theater world she remained a mainstay of
the wacky comedy franchise over the
coming years working on six installments
rapper and actor darren thompson better
known by stage name dzd died of a
suspected heart attack in january 2021
thompson who appeared as affable nurse
malik mcgrath in all 15 seasons of the
beloved medical drama er was discovered
in an unresponsive state at his los
angeles home his brother told tmz he was
55. thompson made his first feature film
appearance in 1991's caller's ice the
critically panned movie debut of vanilla
ice he made his er debut in 1994
beginning a near 200 episode run on the
nbc hit thompson had been dealing with
heart issues for over a decade in 2009
he told radar online that he was
awaiting surgery after quote over 10
episodes of heart failure in the last 8
months alone doctors identified a
problem with his aorta the los angeles
native was still making music and
actively promoting his songs at the time
of his death
british actress barbara shelley who
appeared in numerous hammer horror films
during the 1950s and 60s died in january
2021. the veteran scream queen
contracted kovit 19 after a routine
hospital visit her agent thomas
bowington told the bbc she was 88
shelley trained in theater as a child
but her good looks naturally led her
into the world of modelling her dream
was to act however so when she was
approached with an offer while
vacationing in rome she took a chance
shelley went on to appear in a string of
italian movies over a four year period
but it would be the work she did after
returning to the uk that she would be
best remembered for the londoner became
the go-to female star for hammer horror
appearing in eight of the studio's
classic pictures
let me kiss you
beloved soap star john riley best known
for his 11-year run on abc's general
hospital died in january 2021. the
actor's death was confirmed by one of
his daughters in a tribute instagram
post she wrote imagine the best person
in the world now imagine that person
being your dad i'm so grateful he was
mine i'm so grateful i got to love him
i'm so grateful i made it in time to
hold him and say goodbye he was 86
riley made his on-screen debut in the
midwest set soap opera as the world
turns in the mid-70s and would go on to
become a regular face on american
daytime television he scored recurring
roles on shows like the bionic woman and
how the west was won
tanya roberts was best known for playing
geologist stacy sutton opposite a much
older roger moore in 1985's a view to a
kill the 14th installment in the british
james bond franchise the actress died
from a urinary tract infection that
quote got into her blood and developed
into sepsis her longtime partner lance
o'brien told fox news she was 65. the
new york native started out as a model
but made the transition to acting a
decade before her james bond appearance
landing her part in the horror flick
forced entry her first major role came
in 1980 when she joined the cast of the
then struggling charlie's angels she
remained busy during the 1990s when she
made her first appearance on that 70s
show playing midge pinciatti
croatian american actress mira furlon
best known for her stints on babylon 5
and last died in january 2021
her death was announced on her official
twitter account the cause of death was
not revealed she was 65 born in zagreb
ferlan and her husband emigrated to
america in the early 90s amid rising
tensions in their home country settling
in new york city three years after the
move she landed what would become her
most iconic role in barry ambassador
dilen in babylon 5. she briefly returned
to croatia before jetting off to hawaii
to play the part of danielle russo in
last she appeared as a french loner in
20 episodes of abc's hit show you
offered to fix my music box
after all i've done to you striking you
shocking you
new york born actor gregory sierra who
appeared in 70 sitcoms samford and son
and barney miller died of cancer in
january 2021. his widow helen tabor told
cnn he was doing the best he could and
just couldn't do it anymore he was quite
wonderful and my heart has broken into
400 million pieces he was 83 according
to deadline tierra began his career as a
member of the national shakespeare
company appearing in a number of
off-broadway productions during the
1960s he made his screen debut in a 1969
episode of the robert wagner spy series
it takes a thief he would go on to
become a mainstay of the american tv in
the years that followed popping up in
numerous sitcoms and cop shows
award-winning actress cloris leachman
best known for playing phyllis lindstrom
on the mary tyler moore show and i am
proud
died of natural causes in january 2021
she was quote one of the most fearless
actresses of our time her rap and friend
julia green told variety adding you
never knew what cloris was going to say
or do and that's unpredictable quality
was part of her unparalleled magic she
was 94. a native of iowa leachman moved
to neighbouring illinois to study
theater at northwestern university she
dropped out before she could graduate
and took an unconventional route to
hollywood that included an appearance at
the 1946 miss america pageant her acting
career began when she landed in new york
and got him with the actors studio but
she wouldn't come to national attention
until she debuted on the mary tyler
moore show some 20 years later she won
two of her eight primetime emmy awards
for playing the catty phyllis lindstrom
who would later get her own spin-off
phyllis i'm afraid i've just been
too much of a real woman hollywood
trailblazer sicily tyson who paved a
path for black actresses during a career
that spanned more than six decades died
in january 2021. her manager confirmed
to variety she was 96. the east harlem
native worked as a model before breaking
into acting appearing in top
publications like vogue she learned her
craft at the actor's studio and became a
regular face on the new york theater
scene but she'll no doubt be best
remembered for the work she did and
didn't do on the screen tyson made her
debut in short drama carib gold and
moved into feature films proper when she
appeared as a jazz club worker in the
harry belafonte picture odds against
tomorrow she largely avoided movies in
the decade that followed making a
conscious effort to turn down roles that
demeaned black women she returned to the
big screen with a bang in 1972's sounder
earning a best actress nomination for
her turn as depression-era sharecropper
rebecca morgan you've got your low-life
job mr sheriff
tyson was awarded an honorary oscar in
2019 by which point she was widely
recognized as one of the industry's
pioneers
actor dustin diamond who played iconic
90s geek samuel screech powers and the
sitcom saved by the bell died of cancer
in february 2021 just three weeks after
it was revealed that he'd been diagnosed
with stage four small cell carcinoma in
a statement published in variety his
agent said in that time it managed to
spread rapidly throughout his system the
only mercy he had exhibited was its
sharp and swift execution dustin did not
suffer he was 44. a naturally funny
child diamond landed the role of screech
with next to no on-screen experience he
debuted as a lovable loser in 1988 on
the disney channel's good morning miss
bliss which would be picked up and
revamped into saved by the bell by nbc
when it was canned after a single season
saved by the bell finished in 1992 but
diamond reprised the role of screech on
several occasions in the years that
followed most notably and saved by the
bell to college years and saved by the
bell the new class a california native
appeared in 130 episodes of the new
class from 1994 2000
award-winning star of stage and screen
hal holbrook best known by his portrayal
of mark twain in his enduring one-man
show mark twain tonight died at his
california home in january 2021. his
agent told the new york times he was 95.
his first on stage performances took
place when he was stationed in
newfoundland with the us army he joined
the theater group and appeared in a
number of local productions he began
working on what would eventually become
mark twain tonight in 1952 and four
years later he shot to prominence after
ed sullivan invited him onto his variety
show remarkably holbrook would go on to
perform as twain over 2000 times
including two stints on broadway the
first run scored him a tony award and he
was nominated for an emmy when mark
twain tonight transferred to tv
star of the stage and screen christopher
plummer known for a prolific career that
included playing captain von trapp in
the iconic best picture winner the sound
of music died in february 2021. he was
91. the toronto native made his broadway
bow in 1954's the star cross story and
debuted on the big screen four years
later starring alongside henry thunder
and susan strasberg in stage struck the
actor disliked many of the films he
appeared in during the 1960s including
the one he would come to be best known
for he famously called robert wise's
musical quote the sound of mucus in the
1970s plummer bagged a tony award for
his work on the musical cyrano and then
a prime time emmy for the money changers
nbc's adaptation of arthur haley's
political thriller he was nominated in
the same category for 2017's all the
money in the world a feat made all the
more remarkable by the fact that he
stepped in to replace kevin spacey in
the role of j paul getty just six weeks
before the film was due to be released
actress and singer trisha noble who
played the mother of natalie portman's
padme amidala in the star wars universe
died in january 2021. the australian
died quote after an 18-month battle with
mesothelioma a tumor caused by inhaled
asbestos fibers the daily mail reported
she was 76 born patsy and noble in
marrickville sydney she got her start on
the aussie variety show bandstand which
featured regular performances from the
likes of the beegees and grease star
olivia newton-john noble saw success in
australia but her career wouldn't take
off internationally until she moved to
britain where she secured a record deal
with colombia records she later
relocated again taking the stage name
trisha upon her arrival in the states
she's perhaps best known for playing
jabal nabery in 2005's star wars episode
3 revenge of the sith
actor christopher penick who appeared in
126 episodes of the gothic soap opera
dark shadows and later occurred on
general hospital died in february 2021.
he had been given a melanoma diagnosis
the previous year deadline confirmed he
was 76. panic studied at the american
academy of dramatic arts in new york and
would go on to fine-tune his craft with
the actor's studio before making his
debut on broadway he began with
understudy work but he quickly levelled
up and started landing roles in
productions like 1969's patriot for me
which is where dan curtis first laid
eyes on him the dark shadows creator
cast panic as leviathan the first of
many characters he would portray he's
perhaps best known for the twin roles of
cyrus longworth and john yeager the
in-universe versions of dr jekyll and mr
hyde